[Music]
i'm your host pete seth
and tonight we look at the once bustling
boom town known
as bidenville
it had so much promise such a growing
and busy population tense as far as the
eye could see
but alas the third world city that
sprung up under a bridge in del rio
texas is no more
that's right a week after it sprung up
the illegal town of bidenville
well it's no more
for now
just look at the stark contrast in these
images on your screen of what this camp
looked like on tuesday compared to now
they even brought in the bulldozers that
tidy up tidied up a bit for the after
photos commissioned by cnn and msnbc
but where did all its non-citizens go
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas laid
out the numbers yet again for us this
afternoon
nearly 30 000 migrants
have been encountered at del rio since
september 9 with the highest number one
time reaching approximately fifteen
thousand today we have no migrants
remaining in the camp
thirty thousand illegals came through
bidenville some stayed for a while some
only briefly
that's an entire baseball stadium of
illegals waiting to rush into america
now just yesterday the administration
told us there was still 5000 illegals
left in the government camp so 24 hours
later where do they go
and what happened to the 3 200 people
they told us were being processed
approximately 12
400 individuals will have their cases
her
the individual is placed in immigration
proceedings
he inspires such confidence
now as we shared last night we know that
removal proceedings actually mean being
released into the shadows of the united
states
so did the buy administration just drop
12 000 illegals and likely far far more
into your backyard
the answer is unequivocally yes
but don't worry we have to be testing
these people for covid right surely the
administration that loves forcing
vaccine and mass mandates on
hard-working tax-paying actual american
citizens
must be treating these illegals the same
way
just mentioning koben
what is the situation
there i know that the crowd has been
dispersed
do we know who has tested positive if
people got sick we did not we do not
test we did not test that population of
individuals i do not know whether anyone
was sick with covet
oh we did we
we did not that's a big no
you need a cova test to eat inside a
restaurant in the city i'm in right now
and a mask to fly in a plane
but illegals don't need any of that
to enter america
and if biden had ever been to the border
in his life he might be able to get an
idea on what's going on down there
but three days after fox news pressed
the white house on why biden's never
been to the border
we still have no answers
why hasn't president biden ever visited
the southern border what would you like
him to do at the southern border and
what impact do you think that would have
on the policies
then why visit hurricane disaster areas
or flood zones or go visit war zones
time and time again as biden has
what impact could seeing those images
firsthand possibly have on your policies
jen saki said a lot of dumb things but
this might take the cake bullet at least
for today
so seeing is not understanding better to
make decisions from air-conditioned
offices in washington dc surrounded by
lobbyists
maybe by actually going to texas biden
can see how hard the job of securing our
border actually is
and how much the agents of border patrol
deal with every day from drug busts to
babysitting
instead his administration is focused on
the real crisis or excuse me
the really fake crisis
that border agents were whipping
haitians
this is happening under your watch do
you take responsibility for the chaos
that's unfolding of course i take
responsibility i'm president but i was
horrible what to see as you saw to see
people treat it like they did horses
really running them over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay they will be an
investigation underway now and there
will be consequences
there will be consequences it's an
embarrassment
those people will pay
so the border patrol will pay
guilty of only one thing
actually enforcing the border that
democrats don't give a damn about
any fair investigation will show they
did nothing wrong because they didn't
but that won't matter
they've already been smeared at the
highest levels of our government
the question you heard from the reporter
before joe biden answered
was about the exploding chaos on the
border but all biden could focus on was
a debunked picture and there was no
follow-up questions peter ducey would
have asked it
but he wasn't on the white house
approved three question list
how about we ask the man who actually
took the horse patrol photo
well today he said quote
i've never seen them whip anyone
it can be misconstrued when you're
looking at a picture you think
and leave it to vice president giggles
to double down on the leftist lies even
a covet scare on the set of the view
couldn't keep root causes kamala away
from slamming border patrol
there needs to be consequence and
accountability it also evoked images of
some of the worst moments of our history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african-americans
during times of slavery
i'm sorry kamala didn't indians ride
horses too i'm just asking
but of course i digress
and this whole bit about slavery
shameless
wrong
and straight-up offensive slavery
the only slaves on the border are the
sex slaves the mexican cartels exploit
every day
i guess those people won't pay
will they joe
instead the white house is happy to hang
these agents out to dry in a craven
public relations push to judgment
but at least an impartial investigation
it's underway by their boss
the images horrified us in terms of what
they suggest and what they conjure up in
terms of not only our nation's history
but unfortunately the fact that that
page of history has not been turned
entirely but i will not prejudge the
facts
he defended it when he first saw it a
couple days ago but then he got
corralled by the white house
a little late for the for that one don't
you think secretary
you can't cast your judgment on these
brave border agents and then follow up
with but i'm waiting for the facts
i cannot imagine being a border patrol
agent right now in the united states of
america not allowed to do your job and
if you do you will be the bad guy
it's almost as if the white house hates
border patrol as much as they do the
cops
we know they do
and what does it all add up to
well bidenville might be empty right now
but the message to illegals is even more
clear than ever
the border is open
the border patrol isn't allowed to do
their job
and even if the white house says you're
being removed
you're actually being released
america is wide open
just the way the democrats want it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else